can you work out a question from the
very first SAT exam in 1925 if it takes
five men four days to dig a 100 foot
drain how many men are needed to dig a
200 foot drain in half a day
to work it out we will use dimensional
analysis the number of men times the
number of days times the rate is equal
to the number of feet so we know there
are five men and four days and a hundred
feet which means we can work out the
rate is equal to 100 divided by 5 times
4 which means the rate is equal to 5
feet per man day so now we can
substitute that into the rate and we
need to know how many men it will take
for half a day to equal 200 feet so we
solve this to get 200 divided by five
multiplied by 0.5 which is the same as
200 divided by 2.5 or 400 divided by 5
and that works out to be 80 men and
that's the answer